die grünen haben hochkonjunktur
während spd und fdp von der ampel
koalition in berlin nicht profitieren
können das ist das bundespolitische
signal aus nordrhein westfalen heute
abend habeck und bernburg sind zugpferde
ein nennenswerter scholz effekt für die
sozialdemokraten ist nicht zu erkennen
die fdp verliert im land von christian
lindner geradezu katastrophal
wie ungleich die drei partner hier
abschneiden das wird die bundesregierung
belasten die nähere lage der liberalen
hat vor allem landespolitische ursachen
stichwort bildungsministerin aber es
summiert sich die fdp hat nun bei allen
drei wahlen in diesem jahr schlecht
abgeschnitten keine steuersenkungen
immer neue milliarden-schulden das
gefällt ihrer klientel nicht und es
kommen andere faktoren hinzu die
eigensinnige corona politik und der hang
in sachen ukraine und sicherheitspolitik
gleichzeitig regierung und opposition
sein zu wollen wie die geborene
düsseldorferin marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann
bitte die verluste auch bei den
sozialdemokraten statt eines neustarts
in ihrem kern land fährt die spd mit
thomas kutschaty ihr schlechtestes
ergebnis ein angesichts des großen
abstands zur cdu wirkt es wie
realitätsverlust dass die parteiführung
heute abend dennoch chancen für rot grün
oder einer ampel regierung sieht es gibt
zwei wahlsieger heute abend die grünen
mit ihrem beeindruckenden comeback und
den schnellstart hendrik wüst der
gewinnt hinzu stärker mit den cdu
parteivorsitzenden friedrich merz und
wird wenn es ihm gelingt die grünen zu
sich herüberzuziehen die chance auf die
poleposition als nächster kanzler
kandidat der union haben schwarz grün
ist heute abend die wahrscheinlichste
option für nrw gewiss das wäre eine
zumutung für viele grün wähler aber die
starken grünen könnten die cdu zu einem
energischen klima umbauprogramm zwingen
schwarz-grün im großen nrw das könnte
auch eine alternative für die
bundestagswahl 2005 und 20 aufzeigen
dieses signal tatsächlich aus düsseldorf
zu senden obwohl sie damit misstrauen
auch bei ihren ampel partnern sehen dass
es der preis des grünen erfolgs